what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
fresh's ex
i don't even know sugar baby
girlfriend
girl he was sleeping with
um this video that she put out i have
not seen anyone in the manosphere react
to this i've only seen them react to
like
other stuff so i'm going to react to it
i just want to start off by saying that
i am not ready to make this video i
don't want to make this video
my plan was pretty much to just let
everything pass
and not make a video at all
because
i'm okay with
people hating on me i'm okay with the
hate comments i really don't need people
oh i should probably preface before um
i keep going because i know there's
people that haven't actually watched
like the full beef basically
this girl was talking to fresh and
that's a guy on the fresh and fit
podcast
and
he was saying that oh she likes me for
me she has genuine desire and then it
turns out that she had a bunch of
content about how to like use men for
their money on her different social
media platforms so now she's making a
video on it to believe
my side or pick a side because i don't
think there even should be
but
my name has been constantly drive to the
mud
and
i have a lot of people coming up to me
that i haven't talked to
in a really long time saying that i look
stupid and i do and i'm gonna continue
to look stupid i guess because
pretty much i got finessed in this
situation
but i can only really blame myself i
mean
[Music]
everybody knows
what kind of
brand they have and that's the thing
ladies when a guy tells you who he is
believe him
that's what we do as women like we like
to think we're special or we're
different or it's different with us but
it usually isn't oh
it's really on me
but
if you are new here my name is miranda
and
i'm just gonna
go through all the rumors and tell you
what i think about it
and that's it so
i'm just gonna go right into it and
address the seeking arrangements sugar
baby
entire rumor it's obviously not really a
rumor there's proof that i was on the
site
um however me and fresh did meet on that
site and oh yeah that's the other thing
because one of the pieces of evidence
that they found was that she was on
seeking arrangements which is like a
site
i mean it's pretty self-explanatory for
like
rich guys to meet pretty young girls
completely
like a dating site for me instead of
using a tinder bumble whatever
i realized fairly quickly that i didn't
like
guys my age after my last sex because i
felt like okay maybe like older guys are
more mature
they have their [ __ ] together and maybe
they're more mature
i found that out the hard way that
that's not really the case but
i use seeking arrangements oh come on
you think that they're okay
okay
because
that's just what i found worked for me i
met a good amount of decent people on
that app and what started as more of
like a financial reason because of covid
and not having a job and not being able
to get a job
genuinely turned into wanting to find
somebody that i could be with
and only with
for long term
and not feel the pressure of having to
do everything myself because that's what
i've always felt in past relationships
is that i was always giving giving and
like not getting anything back so i kind
of wanted that
change in my life
and i don't think that there's anything
wrong with being on the site i think
it's still a really great site i think
you meet a lot of good people as long as
you're careful on it
but that being said like i met fresh and
it took a while for us to meet up
because i wasn't in a place where
i felt
i should be meeting up with new people i
wasn't
in a good living situation so there
really was no way for me to be like okay
like yeah you hit me up to go out to
dinner
that's great i'll come so it was a while
before we even met up but he was aware
of
me being on the app or the website
and there was no issue with it until it
went public
but i never asked for fresh like it
never asked fresh for any money he
didn't pay for my apartment
he didn't pay for any clothes
he didn't pay for any of my furniture
which is literally just a bed
um
i genuinely wanted him
for who he was
and i got to know him super well and it
became very apparent to me
that i wanted him to be in my life
somehow
and we just had like a really good
connection
from the very beginning and i knew i
didn't need to ask him for anything i've
never asked anybody for anything even
people that i've met on the site in the
past
it was always a date it was always
hey
um
there was never
i'm gonna meet you here and you're gonna
give me eight hundred dollars
i personally didn't do that i don't like
asking for things
from anyone
you find that a little a little hard to
believe with the content that she was
making
i mean you're accepting money from from
strangers much less somebody that i
don't know
so
there was there's no debate
that fresh was my sugar daddy because he
wasn't
um
and even looking back at it i'm not mad
that i didn't get anything out of the
situation because
he
was great it
it was great well lasted
um but i maybe should have known better
but as far as seeking arrangements
there was no secret there and
it really wasn't until it went public
that it became an issue how are you
broke can you have a dog
dogs are not cheap you should not buy a
dog if you were broke
but
everything was known we've talked about
it and i'm not gonna apologize for being
on the site
and i'm not gonna apologize for people
that i've talked to on the site
because i don't
find anything wrong with it and i
personally know that i don't
consider myself a sugar baby or get
thousands of dollars or
bags or clothing from anyone i don't i
just personally don't do that
that being said i have a tick tock
account which was also
very public recently and i just want to
say that a lot of those tick tocks are a
joke they're either based on a trend
or
they're big my mom always told me
growing up that half kidding is half
serious
you only think of a joke if it comes
from somewhere like something you can
relate to otherwise it's not funny based
on just me
and my life but do i actually
want a sugar daddy that's on his
deathbed and leaves me his inheritance
no i mean would i be mad
if someone left me their inheritance
no
but i don't want to be with an old guy
that's like on his deathbed there's no
connection there i'm not going to be a
housewife so
that's all a joke and i i realize that
people take that way too seriously but
it's
i'm not gonna be upset about the hate
comments that are left on my tick tock
because
it's not that serious it's really not
as well as
the one about
um a certain site i don't know if i want
to say it but there was a tick tock
about a site that's not seeking
arrangements
that i used and all you have to do
is talk to people
so again i'm not gonna apologize that
for that i i didn't do anything wrong
so far
this video is
i did what i did and deal with it
is talk to people and it doesn't even
have to be sexual like
it could be anything there's a lot of
lonely people in this world so i'm not
going to judge some someone for getting
on the site and wanting to talk
to a girl
i'm not going to judge somebody for that
if you want to pay for that if maybe
you're lonely you don't want to go to a
bar maybe you have anxiety and you don't
want to go out if you get online
and you pay people to talk to you
that's on you and again that's on me to
go on that site and talk to them
for payment
i wasn't doing anything wrong
it was
hey how are you and they sent you a
dollar and then it racks up
i'm sorry that you are a man
and you have to pay instead of
being paid for a conversation that just
is what it is and if that sounds
arrogant then i'm sorry but
all of you want to come at me for
stupid things when i was the one who
didn't even have money for a 36 parking
parking ticket but you got money for a
dog
and to live in miami you don't have to
live in miami you could live somewhere
else
like who doesn't have money for a 36
dollar pregnancy ticket
i'm broke all of the time
so
i did what i could
based off of
what i saw online what i could do with
it and i made 36 so i don't think that
there's any harm in that
and i was working
a full-time
internship while being a full-time
student and it wasn't paid
so
my entire day was consumed by work that
i wasn't being paid for
so
i had to do something
i'm not gonna be mad about it i'm not
gonna dwell on it i'm not gonna let you
guys comment
mean things and say that i'm a sugar
baby just because i had a conversation
with somebody for a dollar
so that stuff for me was pretty easy to
talk about because
i don't care what you guys think
no offense um but
i hate comments they don't get to me so
you can comment them all day long
i'll read them but i'll probably laugh
at them
um
but the whole reason why i'm making this
video is
because you know when you see two people
online and they're constantly together
and then suddenly they're not together
anymore and the entire comment section
is what happened
where is she where is he why aren't you
guys together
and they just never post about it and it
just
goes away like nobody ever knows what
happens i used to hate when people did
that
if you're so public online
then make a public announcement of why
you're not anymore
so
i just want
to share why um
we're not together anymore and what the
reasoning is behind that
you might hear a different story from
fresh i'm not sure but
um i got a a message
on instagram from
very nice person
and they basically
said
hey are you okay i feel so bad about
what fresh said about you
um on academics oh my gosh guys if you
want to see what she's about to talk
about
oh my god it's brutal it's in my last
live i would look now but
i'd have to dig through some videos i
don't even remember what video it is but
go to my
two live stream streams ago it's called
reacting to fresh and fits like catching
up or like drama or something like that
and oh my god he was so incredibly
disrespectful to her oh my god i would
have killed somebody
live stream
um i just want you to know that he
probably didn't mean it
and that i hope that everything's well
and at that point i had absolutely no
idea what he was talking about it was
bad it was bad see academics live stream
it was maybe about 24 hours after
it was released that i
that he was messaging me
so immediately
i was like what are you talking about
i i don't know i didn't see anything
can you please
let me know and
he responded and he said
what
pretty much a good summary of what fresh
said about me
so
immediately
i said i don't
think that i deserve that
yeah i can't what did he say he said he
was rating her head game as bad saying
she wasn't that good at sex saying
he didn't care about her he just like to
bust a nut in her like it was
oh my god it was bad if you want like
word for word to hear what he said go to
that live stream and go towards the end
of it but oh
oh my god i knew it was over after i saw
that i blocked him
because
that's just part of my personality is
that when somebody
does something like that to me i don't
feel the need for closure i don't feel
the need to have a whole conversation
and
get over it i would rather you just be
out of my life so that i can
fix it on my own
and realize okay what did you do wrong
and then move on
oh my gosh i hate to say this
i
know when girls cap when they're done
because i've been there like
i'm i'm a girl too
she made this video for fresh to see it
that's why she made the video i i know
females i know girls she's talking about
him in a way to like
let him know that he messed up pretty
much
guarantee she'll talk to him again she
wouldn't have made this video um
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that um that's just what i had to
do i didn't
i didn't do anything to fresh i was
always very loyal i was always very
um i was always there for him
so
i knew that i wasn't really at fault for
what happened
and
i knew that i just had to get over it on
my own
so i haven't spoken
to him in quite a bit but
i did get to watch
the the twitch for myself
and
i know that i would never say that about
him i would always defend him
so to hear him have those things to say
about me
but here another thing
see
see that right there she wants him to
hear that that is directly too fresh oh
my gosh off camera
was
just it it hurt it it definitely hurt
i'm not gonna sit here and cry about it
but
um
that was like my best friend for
like the last month and a half
so
pretty much like that's losing
losing your best friend
out of nowhere
you bet you made a best friend in a
month
oh my gosh that's so quick
like a month really
but
i don't wish him
anything bad i always wish will wish him
the best i hope that he's successful i
hope that he
does well with everything
but for my own
mental health i just knew that that was
it
as far as me and academics go um
i know we don't always see eye to eye on
everything
um for instance
being white does not mean that you're
rich
and
you have a lot of your facts
very wrong
on that that live stream
um
but
you
did show me
somebody's true colors so
i have to say thank you um
because it was probably better that i
found out now
save myself the stress of
like another five months and things
being done behind my back because
a lot of things
did come to my attention after
me and fresh stop talking so
usually i get over it and then
i'm doing well
and then something else someone else
comes to me with another thing that
i didn't know happened so i've just been
like
up and down and up and down
um but sorry that's pretty much
everything that i needed to say if you
guys have any questions oh my gosh
see this like barely got any views in
the menosphere
i feel bad for whoever falls and marries
you oh gosh these comments are not nice
you're a certified gold digger
here's the thing like
do i think she liked him yeah do i think
sorry this is so zoomed in do i think
she was attracted to his money
duh like why else would you be on a
sugar baby site it's not for their
personalities like clearly everyone's
rich and successful on that site
so
i mean i think she'll learn a lesson
from this
um she's young she's only 22. but let me
know what you guys think in the comments
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell i'll talk
to you guys next time